Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. At approximately 1145pm on Monday, April 24, 1995, Constable Robert Cross was manning the public information desk at the Ottawa Carleton Regional Police Headquarters when he saw a man approaching. The man was in his mid-40s with a balding grey hair and a bushy moustache. When the man reached Constable Cross's desk, he informed the officer that he wished to report
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。1995年4月24日星期一晚上11点45分左右，罗伯特·克罗斯警官正在渥太华卡尔顿地区警察总部值守公共信息台，这时他看到一名男子走近。该男子40多岁，头发灰白且稀疏，留着浓密的胡子。当该男子走到克罗斯警官的办公桌前时，他告知警官他想报告
a missing person. The man's name was Brett Morgan. He was worried about his partner, 46-year-old Louise Ellis. Brett had last seen Louise more than 48 hours earlier when she'd left to visit an old friend at around 2pm on Saturday, April 22. The friend lived in a cottage near Wakefield in the Gatano Hills, a forested area in the neighbouring province of Quebec. It was only a 30-minute or so drive from Ottawa until Louise planned to stay there one or two nights. Brett Morgan said she had been cheerful and excited about her weekend retreat. But the following day, Brett received a phone call from Louise's friend saying that she'd never
一起失踪人口案。这名男子的名字叫布雷特·摩根。他很担心他的伴侣，46岁的路易丝·埃利斯。布雷特最后一次见到路易丝是在48个多小时前，当时她在4月22日星期六下午2点左右离开去拜访一位老朋友。这位朋友住在邻省魁北克省加蒂诺山脉韦克菲尔德附近的一间小屋里，那是一个森林茂密的地区。从渥太华开车到那里大约只需要30分钟，路易丝计划在那里住一两个晚上。布雷特·摩根说，她对周末的度假感到非常高兴和兴奋。但第二天，布雷特接到了路易丝朋友的电话，说她从未
arrived. Brett wasn't overly concerned, as Louise had mentioned she might visit another friend in the area as well and spend a night with her. Perhaps she had decided to go there first. But when there was no sign of Louise by Monday evening, Brett began to raise the alarm. He called a number of Louise's friends asking if anyone had seen her. Nobody had. One person Brett called was Brenda Misson, the second friend Louise had planned to visit while away.
到达。布雷特并没有过度担心，因为路易丝曾提到她可能也会去拜访该地区的另一位朋友，并和她住一晚。也许她决定先去那里。但到了周一晚上，路易丝依然不见踪影，布雷特开始拉响警报。他给路易丝的几位朋友打了电话，询问是否有人见过她。没有人见过。布雷特打给的其中一个人是布伦达·米森，这是路易丝计划外出期间要拜访的第二位朋友。
Brenda hadn't seen Louise, but Brett's call jogged a memory. Earlier that day, Brenda had been driving along a rural stretch near her home in Wakefield, Quebec, when she saw a yellow and white Suzuki sidekick Jeep Jeep parked on the shoulder of the road. It was the same make and model as Louise's car. Brenda made a mental note to check whether it belonged to her friend later on. She had forgotten to do so until Brett's call reminded her. Brett rushed to meet Brenda and they inspected the car together. The license plates confirmed it was Louise's car.
布伦达没有见过路易丝，但布雷特的电话唤起了她的记忆。当天早些时候，布伦达开车经过她位于魁北克省韦克菲尔德家附近的一段乡村公路时，看到一辆黄白相间的铃木Sidekick吉普车停在路肩上。这与路易丝的车品牌和型号相同。布伦达在心里记下，稍后要确认一下那是不是她朋友的车。直到布雷特的电话提醒她，她才想起这件事。布雷特赶去见布伦达，他们一起检查了那辆车。车牌证实了那就是路易丝的车。
Its doors were locked. Inside in the back of the vehicle was a wrapped gift Louise had been taking for her friend's daughter, as well as Louise's overnight bag. Her handbag lay on the front passenger seat. Her wallet was inside, along with some cash and all her bank cards. There was no sign of Louise. Brett appeared calm as he relayed his story to Constable Robert Cross, but the officer could hear the worry and concern in his voice.
车门锁着。车后座里放着路易丝要带给朋友女儿的包装好的礼物，以及路易丝的过夜包。她的手提包放在前排乘客座位上。钱包在里面，还有一些现金和她所有的银行卡。没有路易丝的踪迹。布雷特在向罗伯特·克罗斯警官讲述他的故事时显得很冷静，但警官能听出他声音里的担忧和焦虑。
The pair spoke for roughly 30 minutes while Constable Cross filled out the missing persons report with all the details Brett provided. During their conversation, Brett suddenly said something unexpected. He informed the constable that he had previously been convicted of killing a woman. Constable Robert Cross was surprised and disturbed by this revelation. Brett Morgan came across as a loving and caring spouse who was genuinely concerned about his missing partner's welfare, so his admission that he had previously served time for killing another woman was shocking. Brett explained that his previous conviction was a long time ago.
两人交谈了大约30分钟，克罗斯警官根据布雷特提供的所有细节填写了失踪人口报告。在交谈过程中，布雷特突然说了一些意想不到的话。他告知警官，他之前曾因杀害一名女性而被定罪。罗伯特·克罗斯警官对这一披露感到惊讶和不安。布雷特·摩根给人的印象是一位充满爱心和关怀的配偶，他真心担心失踪伴侣的安危，因此他承认自己曾因杀害另一名女性而服刑，这令人震惊。布雷特解释说，他之前的定罪是很久以前的事了。
17 years earlier, when he was in his late 20s, he had gotten mixed up in criminal activity, including break and enters and theft. One night during this period, Brett had been consuming drugs and alcohol with his then girlfriend. At around 2.30 in the morning, he got into an argument with a woman named Gwen Telford, who'd lived in shared accommodation with them. Gwen was 21 and an accomplice to Brett's crimes. Brett had strangled Gwen and was subsequently convicted of manslaughter. He served 10 years, but following his release, he was convicted of new charges relating to fraud,
17年前，当他20多岁时，他卷入了犯罪活动，包括入室盗窃和偷窃。在此期间的一个晚上，布雷特和当时的女友一起吸食了毒品并饮酒。凌晨2点30分左右，他和一名叫格温·特尔福德的女子发生了争执，她和他们住在一起。格温21岁，是布雷特犯罪的同伙。布雷特勒死了格温，随后被判过失杀人罪。他服刑10年，但在获释后，他又因欺诈、
theft, forgery, and escaping custody. Constable Cross found Brett to be remarkably upfront about his criminal past, especially given the nature of his visit. His frank admission and willingness to honestly cooperate was totally at odds with what the officer would have expected for an individual with his history and a newly missing partner. Constable Cross informed Brett that if Louise had been harmed in some way, Brett's record meant that he would naturally be a suspect.
盗窃、伪造和逃避拘留等新指控被定罪。克罗斯警官发现布雷特对自己的犯罪过去非常坦诚，考虑到他此次来访的性质，这尤其令人意外。他坦率的承认和诚实配合的态度，与警官对一个有这种前科且伴侣刚失踪的人所预期的完全不同。克罗斯警官告知布雷特，如果路易丝受到了某种伤害，布雷特的记录意味着他自然会成为嫌疑人。
Brett replied that he understood that and expected that. But he was adamant that he hadn't hurt Louise. She was someone he described as his soulmate and the person who had helped turn his life around. They had met three years earlier in March 1992 while Brett was serving his second sentence. Louise was attending a Supreme Court hearing into the wrongful conviction of a man for murder. She was a freelance writer and hoped to write a book about the case. As Louise sat in the public gallery, Brett Morgan was brought in shackled to testify as a witness. A former cellmate of his had admitted to being the true perpetrator of the crime,
布雷特回答说他理解这一点，也预料到了这一点。但他坚称自己没有伤害路易丝。他形容她是他的灵魂伴侣，是帮助他改过自新的人。他们三年前，即1992年3月，在布雷特服第二个刑期时相识。路易丝当时正在参加一场关于一名男子被错误定罪谋杀案的最高法院听证会。她是一名自由撰稿人，希望写一本关于此案的书。当路易丝坐在公众席上时，布雷特·摩根被戴着镣铐带进来作证。他的一位前狱友承认自己是该罪行的真正肇事者，
and Brett had come forward to testify. Louise, who was a fierce justice advocate, was struck by Brett's courage. His actions wouldn't make him popular with his fellow inmates. After Brett finished testifying, he was escorted back out of the courtroom. Louise followed him to the elevator where he was flanked by two guards. She tapped one of the guards on his elbow and said, I'd like to have a word with Brett. She then made eye contact with Brett and told him,
而布雷特挺身而出作证。路易丝是一位坚定的正义倡导者，她被布雷特的勇气所打动。他的行为不会让他受到狱友们的欢迎。布雷特作证结束后，被护送出法庭。路易丝跟着他来到电梯旁，他被两名警卫夹在中间。她拍了拍其中一名警卫的胳膊肘说：“我想和布雷特说句话。”然后她与布雷特进行了眼神交流，并告诉他：
I think what you did was really brave. Brett smiled and thanked her. Louise subsequently wrote a letter to Brett and they struck up a friendship, then a romantic relationship while he served out his sentence. They communicated via letters, phone calls and eventually had in-person visits. In 1994, Louise helped Brett with his parole application, hiring lawyers for him and staying in constant contact via the telephone. Her efforts paid off and in May 1994 Brett Morgan left prison on parole. Louise was there to pick him up in her yellow Suzuki sidekick and she bought him an ice cream
“我觉得你所做的事情非常勇敢。”布雷特微笑着感谢了她。路易丝随后给布雷特写了一封信，他们建立起了友谊，并在他服刑期间发展成了恋爱关系。他们通过信件、电话交流，最终进行了面对面的探视。1994年，路易丝帮助布雷特申请假释，为他聘请律师，并通过电话保持密切联系。她的努力得到了回报，1994年5月，布雷特·摩根假释出狱。路易丝开着她的黄色铃木Sidekick去接他，并在回家的路上给他买了一个冰淇淋
cake to celebrate on the way home. Brett moved in with her and she had helped him establish a home renovation business. They had been a happy couple who were often observed by a neighbour sitting on the front porch together holding hands. Although Constable Cross saw nothing in Brett Morgan's demeanour that made him suspicious, Brett's background meant he couldn't be treated like an ordinary citizen. Constable Cross asked Brett if he would accompany him to the criminal investigation department to speak with detectives. Brad agreed. He repeated his story to two detectives who listened attentively and took notes. They asked Brett to come back to the station the following day with photographs of Louise
蛋糕来庆祝。布雷特搬去和她住在一起，她帮助他建立了一家房屋装修公司。他们是一对幸福的伴侣，邻居经常看到他们坐在前廊上手牵手。尽管克罗斯警官在布雷特·摩根的举止中没有发现任何让他怀疑的地方，但布雷特的背景意味着他不能被当作普通公民对待。克罗斯警官问布雷特是否愿意陪他去刑事调查部门与侦探交谈。布雷特同意了。他向两名侦探重复了他的故事，侦探们认真倾听并做了笔记。他们要求布雷特第二天带着路易丝的照片回到警局，
for a missing person's poster. Brett Morgan returned to the police station the following morning, accompanied by a friend of his and Louise. Detectives wanted to interview Brett again. Although he seemed anxious to get on with searching for his partner, Brett obliged. After the 90-minute interview concluded, Brett told his friends that the detectives had put quite a bit of heat on him during the interrogation, wanting to know all the details of his recent movements. Brett didn't seem happy about this development, but told his friend he would do whatever he had to if it helped them bind Louise. As it stood, there was no evidence that a crime had been committed. All of the detectives who spoke to Brett Morgan found him to be a calm, political.
用于制作失踪人口海报。布雷特·摩根第二天早上在一位他和路易丝共同的朋友的陪同下回到了警察局。侦探们想再次审问布雷特。尽管他似乎急于继续寻找他的伴侣，但布雷特还是配合了。90分钟的审讯结束后，布雷特告诉他的朋友，侦探们在审讯过程中给了他相当大的压力，想知道他最近行踪的所有细节。布雷特对这一进展似乎并不高兴，但他告诉朋友，如果这能帮助他们找到路易丝，他愿意做任何事。目前，没有证据表明发生了犯罪。所有与布雷特·摩根交谈过的侦探都发现他是一个冷静、
and cooperative witness, as well as a clearly worried spouse. Brett's parole officer reported to detectives that Brett was doing well on parole and there seemed to be no problems between him and Louise. Detectives asked Brett if they could see Louise's will and he obligingly showed it to them. It turned out that he was Louise's sole beneficiary, but by law he would receive nothing for seven years unless she was confirmed to be deceived. Brett also handed over Louise's financial records and her private diaries. The following day of Wednesday, April 26, a search party assembled outside a restaurant in the town of Wakefield, Quebec,
且配合的证人，也是一个显然很担心的配偶。布雷特的假释官向侦探报告说，布雷特在假释期间表现良好，他和路易丝之间似乎没有任何问题。侦探问布雷特是否可以查看路易丝的遗嘱，他欣然向他们展示了。结果发现他是路易丝的唯一受益人，但根据法律，除非她被确认死亡，否则他在七年内什么也得不到。布雷特还交出了路易丝的财务记录和私人日记。第二天，即4月26日星期三，一个搜救队在魁北克省韦克菲尔德镇的一家餐馆外集合，
close to where Louise's car had been found. As well as Ottawa detectives and local police officers from Quebec, Brett Morgan and members of Louisa's family were present. The group spanned out from the area of River Road where Louise's car was parked. There was nothing wrong with the vehicle that might have prompted Louise to abandon it there and its tank was full of petrol. A couple who lived nearby told police they'd noticed the Jeep parked there since Saturday, April 22, the day Louise had left for her trip.
靠近路易丝的车被发现的地方。除了渥太华的侦探和来自魁北克的当地警官外，布雷特·摩根和路易丝的家人也出席了。搜寻小组从路易丝停车的河路区域向外扩展。车辆没有任何故障可能导致路易丝将其遗弃在那里，而且油箱里加满了汽油。一对住在附近的夫妇告诉警方，他们从4月22日星期六，也就是路易丝出发去旅行的那天起，就注意到那辆吉普车停在那里。
It was towed to a nearby garage where an officer would later date a day. us asked it for prints. The area surrounding River Road was densely wooded, and spring rain had made it muddy. Police officers and Louise's loved ones tramped through the cold, scouring the bushes and trees for any trace of Louise. They looked through piles of lumber and felled trees, as well as a nearby ridge that was dotted with boulders and a derelict car. They found nothing.
它被拖到了附近的一个车库，一名警官后来对它进行了指纹采集。河路周围的区域树木茂密，春雨使地面变得泥泞。警官和路易丝的亲人们冒着寒冷，在灌木丛和树木中搜寻路易丝的任何踪迹。他们搜查了成堆的木材和倒下的树木，以及附近一个布满巨石和一辆废弃汽车的山脊。他们什么也没发现。
Over the following days, divers would search the nearby Gattano River, but also came up empty-handed. While the police searches were dialed down, Brett Morgan kept looking. He followed up leads and printed his own posters featuring a photo of Louise and requests for any witnesses to come forward. Brett also gave interviews with the press. He was frank about his past, telling the Ottawa citizen, quote, was convicted of manslaughter and it involved a woman. I understand the implications of that. I have to be a suspect. It's obvious. But he was adamant that he would never harm the woman who had given him a life free from crime. He felt lost now he was alone without her.
在接下来的几天里，潜水员搜查了附近的加蒂诺河，但也一无所获。虽然警方的搜查力度减弱了，但布雷特·摩根一直在寻找。他跟进线索，并打印了自己的海报，上面印有路易丝的照片，并请求任何目击者挺身而出。布雷特还接受了媒体采访。他坦诚地谈到了自己的过去，告诉《渥太华公民报》：“我曾因过失杀人罪被定罪，涉及一名女性。我明白这意味着什么。我必须成为嫌疑人。这是显而易见的。”但他坚称，他绝不会伤害那个给了他无犯罪生活的女人。没有她，他感到迷失。
On Saturday, April 29, one week after Louise had gone missing, Brett spent the day standing at the site where Louise's Suzuki sidekick was found, with a stack of his homemade posters. He flagged downpassing cars and told their occupants about his missing spouse in an effort to raise awareness and find potential leads. I can't rely on the police, he said. It's hard living at home, not knowing where she is. Police told the media that there was no evidence of any foul play, with one Ottawa detective stating, People go missing every day. She may have just gotten tired of this world and walked away.
4月29日星期六，路易丝失踪一周后，布雷特花了一整天时间站在发现路易丝铃木Sidekick的地方，手里拿着一叠他自制的海报。他拦下过往的车辆，告诉车上的人关于他失踪伴侣的情况，试图提高人们的意识并寻找潜在的线索。“我不能依赖警察，”他说。“住在家里，不知道她在哪里，这很难受。”警方告诉媒体，没有证据表明有任何谋杀行为，一位渥太华侦探表示：“人们每天都在失踪。她可能只是厌倦了这个世界，然后离开了。”
During conversations with Brett Morgan, one detective mentioned another case he'd worked on in which a woman had vanished without a trace. His colleagues had immediately decided her husband had murdered her, but then the woman was found alive and well, living in another city. It turned out she'd just wanted to get away. The detective said he didn't want to jump to the same conclusion again. Investigators in Quebec were equally reluctant, telling journalists it wasn't their investigation
在与布雷特·摩根的谈话中，一位侦探提到了他曾处理过的另一个案件，其中一名女子消失得无影无踪。他的同事们立即断定她的丈夫谋杀了她，但后来发现该女子还活着，生活在另一个城市。原来她只是想离开。这位侦探说，他不想再次草率地得出同样的结论。魁北克的调查人员也同样不情愿，告诉记者这不是他们的调查，
as there was nothing to indicate Louise was on their side of the border, despite her car being left there. Despite police agencies downplaying the situation, the rumour mill went into overdrive. It was revealed that Louise Ellis had paid for a small, add to run in the wanted section of a Wakefield newspaper, which read, Responsible Nature Lover Seeks Comfortable Quiet Cottage. Friends confirmed that Louise had spoken about wanting to lease a vacation cottage for the upcoming summer. It was speculated that perhaps she had been intending to visit rental properties while in the area. Others wondered if perhaps Louise had disappeared into the wilderness with the intention of taking her own life.
因为没有任何迹象表明路易丝在他们那边的边境，尽管她的车被留在了那里。尽管警方机构淡化了这种情况，但谣言四起。据透露，路易丝·埃利斯曾花钱在韦克菲尔德一家报纸的征求启事栏刊登了一则小广告，上面写着：“负责任的自然爱好者寻找舒适安静的小屋。”朋友们证实，路易丝确实谈到过想在即将到来的夏天租一间度假小屋。有人推测，也许她打算在那个地区时顺便看看出租房产。其他人则怀疑路易丝是否可能为了自杀而消失在荒野中。
Rumors also spread that a stranger might have ambushed and abducted her, leaving her car behind on the side of the road. Brett Morgan dismissed the suicide theories and kept searching, telling the media, She's my sweetheart, she wouldn't give up on me, and I'm not going to give up on her. Brett rejected the idea that Louise had decided to abandon their life together without a word. He suspected foul play, but he wasn't pointing the finger at a stranger. Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads.
谣言还传播说，可能有一个陌生人伏击并绑架了她，把她的车留在了路边。布雷特·摩根驳斥了自杀理论，并继续寻找，告诉媒体：“她是我的心上人，她不会放弃我，我也不会放弃她。”布雷特拒绝接受路易丝决定不辞而别放弃他们共同生活的想法。他怀疑有谋杀行为，但他并没有指责陌生人。Case File节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。
By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. When Louise Ellis first met Brett Morgan, she was already in a relationship. She had met her former partner John Maysornwev four years earlier at a jazz festival. The pair moved in together several months after meeting, but it was a volatile on-and-off again relationship. When Louise saw Brett Morgan in the courtroom and was immediately transfixed by him, it marked the end of her relationship with John Maisonwev. He left Louise after she started speaking with Brett regularly.
通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。当路易丝·埃利斯第一次见到布雷特·摩根时，她已经有了伴侣。她在四年前的一次爵士音乐节上认识了前伴侣约翰·梅森韦夫。两人在相识几个月后搬到了一起，但这是一种不稳定的分分合合的关系。当路易丝在法庭上看到布雷特·摩根并立即被他吸引时，这标志着她与约翰·梅森韦夫关系的终结。在她开始与布雷特频繁交谈后，他离开了路易丝。
John took her. the breakup badly. He refused to speak to Louise and the pair lost contact for over a year. Then they started talking again in the summer of 1994, not long after Brett Morgan was released from prison and moved in with Louise. There was no longer a romantic element to Louise and John's relationship, but they were able to become friends. John had a daughter from a previous relationship, and Louise was very fond of her. On the weekend that Louise went missing, John was the friend who she'd been planning to stay with in the Gatineau Hills. It was his daughter's 12th birthday, and Louise had packed a gift-wrapped book about horses for the young girl.
约翰对分手感到非常痛苦。他拒绝与路易丝交谈，两人失联了一年多。然后他们在1994年夏天开始重新交谈，就在布雷特·摩根出狱并搬去与路易丝同住后不久。路易丝和约翰的关系中不再有浪漫成分，但他们能够成为朋友。约翰有一个前一段关系生的女儿，路易丝非常喜欢她。路易丝失踪的那个周末，约翰就是她计划去住的朋友。那是他女儿的12岁生日，路易丝打包了一本关于马的包装精美的书送给那个小女孩。
Her car was found with this present inside, not far from John's cottage. Brett Morgan told police he didn't have a problem with Louise visiting her ex for the weekend, as he knew they were just friends. When he'd received a call from John Maisoenwev the day after Louise left, saying she'd never arrived, Brett assumed she'd just decided to visit Brenda Misson instead. After Louise failed to return home and her car was found near John's cottage, Brett's attitude changed. detectives knew they needed to speak to John Maysornwev, and they visited him at his workplace, the University of Ottawa. He said that he'd last spoken to Louise on the evening of Friday,
她的车被发现时，这份礼物就在里面，离约翰的小屋不远。布雷特·摩根告诉警方，他不介意路易丝周末去拜访她的前任，因为他知道他们只是朋友。当他在路易丝离开后的第二天接到约翰·梅森韦夫的电话，说她从未到达时，布雷特以为她只是决定去拜访布伦达·米森了。在路易丝未能回家且她的车在约翰的小屋附近被发现后，布雷特的态度发生了变化。侦探们知道他们需要与约翰·梅森韦夫谈谈，于是他们拜访了他工作的地方——渥太华大学。他说他最后一次与路易丝交谈是在周五晚上，
April 21, the day before she left. John had invited Louise to his family's cottage for dinner that night, but she had declined the invitation. John said that he hadn't been expecting Louise to visit the following day, even though Brett Morgan and one of Louise's friends were aware of this plan. Moreover, John had called his ex-wife on Sunday, April 23, to express his concern that Louise hadn't arrived. He'd also alerted Brett Morgan. John claimed that on the day Louise disappeared, he'd picked up his daughter from horse riding and then spent the day with her. Investigators didn't verify this alibi at the time, as they felt certain it was true. They didn't believe that anyone would implicate their young daughter if they had committed a crime.
4月21日，她离开的前一天。约翰那天晚上邀请路易丝去他家的小屋吃晚饭，但她拒绝了邀请。约翰说，他并没有期待路易丝第二天会来访，尽管布雷特·摩根和路易丝的一位朋友都知道这个计划。此外，约翰在4月23日星期日给他的前妻打了电话，表达了他对路易丝没有到达的担忧。他还提醒了布雷特·摩根。约翰声称，在路易丝失踪的那天，他接了女儿去骑马，然后和她待了一整天。调查人员当时没有核实这个不在场证明，因为他们确信这是真的。他们不相信如果有人犯了罪，会把他们年幼的女儿牵扯进来。
However, they did take sniffer dogs to a secluded lot owned by John May Zornwev to see if they could uncover any trace of the missing woman. They found nothing. With no sign of Louise and no evidence as to her whereabouts, the case stalled. Investigators wondered if she might have been targeted by an enemy of Brett Morgan's, namely the former cellmate he'd implicated in the murder of a woman. The cellmate was named Larry Fisher, and at the time of Louise's disappearance, he was a free man, not yet charged with the murder he was accused of. What if Larry Fisher had targeted Louise Ellis as an act of revenge against Brett Morgan for ratting him out?
然而，他们确实带着嗅探犬去了约翰·梅森韦夫拥有的一块偏僻地块，看看能否发现失踪女子的任何踪迹。他们什么也没发现。由于没有路易丝的踪迹，也没有关于她下落的证据，案件陷入了僵局。调查人员怀疑她是否可能成为了布雷特·摩根敌人的目标，即那个被他牵连进谋杀案的前狱友。那个狱友名叫拉里·费舍尔，在路易丝失踪时，他是一个自由人，尚未因他被指控的谋杀罪受到起诉。如果拉里·费舍尔将路易丝·埃利斯作为报复布雷特·摩根告密的目标会怎样？
Detectives looked into Fisher's whereabouts on the day in question and found that on the morning of Saturday, April 22, Fisher was the subject of a police roadstop in Saskatchewan. This was roughly 3,000 kilometres away from where Louise's car was found, ruling Fisher out of the investigation. Meanwhile, by early May, Brett Morgan had hired two private investigators to follow up on the various leads that were trickling in. He told the Ottawa citizen that he had done so because the local police force was understaffed and unable to keep up with the investigation.
侦探们调查了费舍尔在事发当天的行踪，发现4月22日星期六早上，费舍尔在萨斯喀彻温省接受了警方路检。这距离发现路易丝车的地方大约有3000公里，排除了费舍尔的嫌疑。与此同时，到5月初，布雷特·摩根聘请了两名私家侦探来跟进陆续出现的各种线索。他告诉《渥太华公民报》，他这样做是因为当地警力不足，无法跟上调查进度。
When a television news reporter asked Brett how he was feeling, Brett replied, Increasingly terror-filled. Marie Perrant was a businesswoman based in St Pierre de Wakefield, Quebec. Originally from Scotland, she had relocated to Canada in 1990 in an effort to build a relationship with her estranged father, who was French-Canadian. Once settled, she took ownership of a restaurant and a video store, but neither of these businesses were her true passion. Marie was more interested in detective work. In February of 1995, she enrolled in a three-month course at the Academy of Private Investigators, with a view
当电视新闻记者问布雷特感觉如何时，布雷特回答说：“越来越恐惧。”玛丽·佩兰是一位在魁北克省圣皮埃尔德韦克菲尔德经商的商人。她原籍苏格兰，1990年移居加拿大，试图与她疏远的法裔加拿大父亲建立关系。定居后，她接手了一家餐馆和一家录像带店，但这两项业务都不是她的真正热情所在。玛丽对侦探工作更感兴趣。1995年2月，她报名参加了私家侦探学院为期三个月的课程，旨在
to maybe becoming an investigator herself one day. As the course was nearing completion, Marie heard about the disappearance of freelance writer Louise Alice. Louise's car was found just 25 minutes away from Marie's home and the news coverage of the event caught Marie's attention. Marie had a particular interest in helping women who were victims of violence and while there was no clear evidence that Louise had been attacked, it was obvious that something about the situation was wrong.
也许有一天能成为一名调查员。随着课程接近尾声，玛丽听说了自由撰稿人路易丝·埃利斯的失踪事件。路易丝的车被发现的地方距离玛丽家只有25分钟的路程，该事件的新闻报道引起了玛丽的注意。玛丽对帮助遭受暴力的女性有着特殊的兴趣，虽然没有明确证据表明路易丝受到了攻击，但很明显情况有些不对劲。
Marie's attention was also drawn to Louise's partner, Brett Morgan. She watched him appear on news updates about the case, where he was visibly upset and helpless. Marie's heart went out to him. She wondered if Louise's disappearance could be a chance for her to practically apply the skills she learned in her private investigator course. On Wednesday, May 17, 1995, Marie Permanaghine, called Brett Morgan's home number and left a message on his answering machine, offering to help him.
玛丽的注意力也被路易丝的伴侣布雷特·摩根所吸引。她看着他出现在关于此案的新闻更新中，他显得非常不安和无助。玛丽对他深表同情。她想知道路易丝的失踪是否可能是她应用在私家侦探课程中学到的技能的机会。1995年5月17日星期三，玛丽·佩兰拨打了布雷特·摩根的家庭电话，并在他的答录机上留言，主动提出帮助他。
He called her back two hours later, but explained he already had two private investigators working the case, and he couldn't afford to pay a third. Marie reassured him that she didn't want any money, she just wanted to help and gain some professional experience. The pair agreed to meet, and two days later, Marie drove over to the double-story Red Brick Home. in Old Ottawa South where Louise and Brett lived. Marie had brought along a tape recorder and asked Brett if he minded her taping their conversation. He didn't, and Marie hit record as they began to speak at the couple's kitchen table. They discussed the events of the weekend that Louise went missing and speculated as to what might have happened.
他两小时后回了电话，但解释说他已经有两名私家侦探在处理此案，他负担不起第三个人的费用。玛丽向他保证，她不想要任何钱，她只是想帮忙并获得一些专业经验。两人同意见面，两天后，玛丽开车前往位于渥太华老南区的那栋两层红砖房，那是路易丝和布雷特居住的地方。玛丽带了一台录音机，问布雷特是否介意她录下他们的谈话。他不介意，玛丽按下录音键，他们开始在餐桌旁交谈。他们讨论了路易丝失踪那个周末发生的事件，并推测可能发生了什么。
A few different scenarios were considered, including that Louise might have been a abducted by a stranger. Perhaps someone had parked their vehicle on the shoulder and feigned car trouble, and when Louise pulled over to help, they grabbed her. Brett Morgan eventually told Marie that he had a specific suspect in mind. He believed that Louise's ex, John Maisormweb, was behind her disappearance. John's cottage wasn't far from the area of River Road where Louise's car was found. Brett thought the police should be looking at John, but they didn't seem interested. Over the next few weeks, Marie began conducting her own investigation. She met with Brett Morgan again and spoke with him over the phone a number of times.
考虑了几种不同的情况，包括路易丝可能被陌生人绑架。也许有人把车停在路肩上假装车坏了，当路易丝停下来帮忙时，他们抓住了她。布雷特·摩根最终告诉玛丽，他心里有一个特定的嫌疑人。他认为路易丝的前任约翰·梅森韦夫是她失踪的幕后黑手。约翰的小屋离发现路易丝车的地方——河路区域不远。布雷特认为警方应该调查约翰，但他们似乎不感兴趣。在接下来的几周里，玛丽开始进行自己的调查。她再次与布雷特·摩根见面，并多次与他通电话。
But Marie had more difficulty making contact with Louise's other loved ones. Most of Louise's family and friends wouldn't talk to her. After visiting the area where Louise's... Louise's Jeep had been abandoned, Marie began to agree with Brett Morgan that a random attack by a stranger wasn't likely. The Jeep had been locked up with all of Louise's things inside. If Louise had only gotten out for a moment to help someone in need or had been dragged out against her will, then why would she have locked the doors? Marie kept a digging and one month after taking on the case, she had a breakthrough. She asked Brett Morgan to speak with her so she could update him.
但玛丽在联系路易丝的其他亲人方面遇到了更多困难。路易丝的大多数家人和朋友都不愿与她交谈。在参观了路易丝的吉普车被遗弃的区域后，玛丽开始同意布雷特·摩根的观点，即陌生人的随机袭击不太可能。吉普车锁着，里面放着路易丝所有的东西。如果路易丝只是下车帮忙，或者被强行拖走，那么她为什么要锁上车门呢？玛丽继续挖掘，在接手案件一个月后，她取得了突破。她要求布雷特·摩根与她交谈，以便她向他通报情况。
On Tuesday, June 20, almost two months after Louise went missing, the pair met up again. Marie explained that she had convinced John Maison Weev to be interviewed and had noticed a few discrepancies in his version of events. She had also spoken to a friend of Johns who had told her something John had confided in them. According to this friend, John and Louise had gotten into an argument because John wanted Louise to leave Brett, but she refused. Marie was coming around to Brett's theory that John Maisonwev had killed Louise. She asked Brett what he thought John would have done with Louise's body. Brett didn't think John would have taken it far. Carrying a dead body would be like carrying a sack of potatoes, he said.
6月20日星期二，在路易丝失踪近两个月后，两人再次见面。玛丽解释说，她已经说服约翰·梅森韦夫接受采访，并注意到他讲述的事件版本中存在一些差异。她还与约翰的一位朋友交谈过，那个人告诉了她约翰私下透露的一些事情。据这位朋友说，约翰和路易丝发生了争执，因为约翰想让路易丝离开布雷特，但她拒绝了。玛丽开始倾向于布雷特的理论，即约翰·梅森韦夫杀害了路易丝。她问布雷特，他认为约翰会如何处理路易丝的尸体。布雷特认为约翰不会带走太远。他说，搬运一具尸体就像搬运一袋土豆。
Most likely, John would have dragged Louise into some nearby bush, maybe just 50 or 60 feet in from the road. Marie suggested that the two of them go searching for Louise together. If they could recover her remains, then John Maisonweb would be charged with murder. Four days later, Marie-Parrant and Brett Morgan met up near Wakefield at around noon, then headed together towards John Maison-Wev's cottage. They spent five hours searching the nearby woods, driving along dusty country roads, and occasionally pulling over to cast their eyes over the brush. But they found nothing.
最有可能的是，约翰会把路易丝拖进附近的灌木丛，也许离路边只有50或60英尺。玛丽建议他们两人一起去寻找路易丝。如果他们能找到她的遗体，那么约翰·梅森韦夫就会被控谋杀。四天后，玛丽·佩兰和布雷特·摩根在中午左右在韦克菲尔德附近见面，然后一起前往约翰·梅森韦夫的小屋。他们花了五个小时搜寻附近的树林，沿着尘土飞扬的乡村道路行驶，偶尔停下来观察灌木丛。但他们什么也没发现。
Undeterred, Marie kept working the case. Soon she had another update. A few days later, she met up with Brett again at a local restaurant to tell him that John Maisonwev had taken a polygraph test and failed. Brett remained adamant that Louise's body must be somewhere near John's cottage. The pair made plans to go out searching again the following day. But their plans fell through at the last minute when Brett left a message saying he couldn't make it. He was too distraught at the prospect of finding Louise's body.
玛丽没有气馁，继续处理此案。很快她又有了新的进展。几天后，她再次在一家当地餐馆与布雷特见面，告诉他约翰·梅森韦夫接受了测谎仪测试，但没有通过。布雷特仍然坚称路易丝的尸体一定在约翰的小屋附近。两人计划第二天再次去搜寻。但他们的计划在最后一刻落空了，因为布雷特留下一条信息说他去不了。他因为想到可能会找到路易丝的尸体而感到太痛苦了。
The thought of it had kept him up all night and he hadn't had much sleep. The pair arranged to go through. searching another day, but Brett cancelled those plans as well. Frustrated, Marie told Brett that she was fed up with his lack of cooperation and by the way he was leaving all the work to her. Brett apologised and the pair finally met up again at a local restaurant. They sat outside and drank beers while discussing the case. Marie told Brett that it was imperative they find Louise.
这个想法让他彻夜难眠，他几乎没怎么睡。两人安排改天再去搜寻，但布雷特也取消了那些计划。玛丽感到沮丧，告诉布雷特她受够了他的不配合，以及他把所有工作都留给她做的方式。布雷特道歉了，两人终于又在一家当地餐馆见面。他们坐在外面喝着啤酒讨论案情。玛丽告诉布雷特，找到路易丝是当务之急。
The police wouldn't be able to lay charges without a body, and any inheritance that Brett was entitled to would be tied up as long as she was only a missing person. Brett finally acquiesced and said he would go looking with her the following day. On Thursday, July 6, 1995, Marie Perrant and Brett Morgan met up in Wakefield once again. They began to search a particular wooded section, with Brett driving Marie along various roads throughout the area. Sometimes he would backtrack over a road he'd just headed down as though he was lost.
没有尸体，警方将无法提起诉讼，而且只要她只是失踪人口，布雷特有权获得的任何遗产都将被冻结。布雷特终于默许了，说他第二天会和她一起去寻找。1995年7月6日星期四，玛丽·佩兰和布雷特·摩根再次在韦克菲尔德见面。他们开始搜寻一个特定的林区，布雷特开车带着玛丽穿过该地区的各种道路。有时他会折回他刚刚走过的路，好像迷路了一样。
At one point he told Marie, I don't have a clue where I am. Finally, they arrived at Irwin Road, an obscure dead-end dirt road about 10 kilometres west of Wakefield. A dense thicket of trees separated the road from the forest within. Brett led Marie through the wooded area, pushing back branches as they walked. They exited the tree line and came across it clearing with a pine tree. Pine needles and dead branches that had fallen from the tree were scattered all over the ground.
有一次他告诉玛丽：“我一点头绪都没有，不知道我在哪里。”最后，他们到达了欧文路，这是一条位于韦克菲尔德以西约10公里的偏僻死胡同土路。茂密的树丛将道路与里面的森林隔开。布雷特带着玛丽穿过林区，边走边拨开树枝。他们走出树线，来到一个有一棵松树的空地。从树上掉下来的松针和枯枝散落在地上。
Marie noticed something else lying nearby and said, Look, there's something over there, Brett. Clothing was strewn about, including a blue coat, a sweater, and two running. shoes. What appeared to be a bone was protruding from the sweater. Lying a couple of feet away from the clothing was dark brown human hair, and on a mossy patch right by the coat was a human skull. It's Louise, said Brett Morgan, before bursting into tears. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads.
玛丽注意到附近还有别的东西，说：“看，那边有东西，布雷特。”衣服散落在各处，包括一件蓝色外套、一件毛衣和两只跑鞋。毛衣里似乎有一根骨头露了出来。离衣服几英尺远的地方躺着深棕色的头发，在靠近外套的一块苔藓地上有一个人类头骨。“是路易丝，”布雷特·摩根说着，然后泪流满面。Case File节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。
By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content. Detective Bob Pulfer had been one of the first Ottawa investigators to review Louise Ellis's missing persons report after Brett Morgan filed it. He'd also conducted one of Brett's early interviews and was struck by his polite and cooperative demeanor. Although Ottawa detectives were intrigued by Brett's criminal history, they had held no suspicions at this stage and viewed him only as a witness. On the evening of Friday, April 28, five days after Louise was reported missing,
通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Case File继续提供高质量的内容。鲍勃·普尔弗侦探是布雷特·摩根提交路易丝·埃利斯失踪人口报告后，第一批审查该报告的渥太华调查员之一。他还对布雷特进行了早期的采访之一，并被他礼貌和配合的态度所打动。尽管渥太华的侦探们对布雷特的犯罪记录很感兴趣，但他们在这个阶段没有任何怀疑，只把他视为证人。4月28日星期五晚上，在路易丝被报告失踪五天后，
Detective Pulfer was following up on some of Brett's statements. Brett had told investigators that on the last day Louise was seen, he had gone to the bank at around noon to deposit a check for Louise in the amount of $3,700. On his way home, he stopped at a 7-Eleven store and, and used Louise's bank card to withdraw $250 for himself. Brett arrived home at around 1pm, gave Louise her bank card back, and she departed between 1 and 2. However, when Detective Pulver checked Louise's bank records, he found the deposit had been made at 132pm, and Brett withdrew the $250 at 253 p.m.
普尔弗侦探正在跟进布雷特的一些陈述。布雷特告诉调查人员，在路易丝最后一次露面的那天，他中午左右去了银行，为路易丝存了一张3700美元的支票。在回家的路上，他在一家7-Eleven便利店停下来，用路易丝的银行卡为自己取了250美元。布雷特在下午1点左右回到家，把银行卡还给了路易丝，她在1点到2点之间离开。然而，当普尔弗侦探检查路易丝的银行记录时，他发现存款是在下午1点32分存入的，而布雷特在下午2点53分取走了250美元。
This significant discrepancy was enough to make the detective suspicious. He requested Brett be placed under 24-hour surveillance. A wiretap issue was ordered and a bug was placed on Brett Morgan's phone. The discrepancy in Brett's statement wasn't the only cause for suspicion. Although he presented as a soft-spoken man with a rough past who'd redeemed his ways, the truth was more alarming. Decades earlier, when Brett Morgan was 15 years old, he had gotten into a romantic relationship with a girl one year his senior named Sandra, who became pregnant.
这一重大差异足以让侦探产生怀疑。他要求对布雷特进行24小时监视。下达了窃听令，并在布雷特·摩根的电话上安装了窃听器。布雷特陈述中的差异并不是怀疑的唯一原因。尽管他表现为一个有着粗糙过去但已改过自新的轻声细语的人，但事实却更令人震惊。几十年前，当布雷特·摩根15岁时，他与一个比他大一岁的名叫桑德拉的女孩谈恋爱，她怀孕了。
Brett had lied to Sandra about his age, telling her he was actually 18, and when she found out the truth, she was deeply disturbed. The relationship soon turned abusive with Brett hitting, slapping and pushing Sandra. The young couple broke up, but Brett begged for a second chance. They got married and Sandra gave birth to a boy named Christopher. The abuse continued and escalated, with Brett now choking Sandra, dragging her around by her hair and throwing his boots at her. Once again she left him, this time moving back to her hometown.
布雷特对桑德拉撒了谎，说他其实18岁，当她发现真相时，她深受打击。这段关系很快变得充满虐待，布雷特对桑德拉拳打脚踢、推搡。这对年轻夫妇分手了，但布雷特乞求第二次机会。他们结婚了，桑德拉生下了一个名叫克里斯托弗的男孩。虐待持续并升级，布雷特现在开始掐桑德拉的脖子，抓着她的头发拖着她走，并把靴子扔向她。她再次离开了他，这次搬回了她的家乡。
She and Brett later reconciled and the cycle of violence continued. Sandra became pregnant with the couple's second child, But during a fight, Brett repeatedly punched her in the stomach, which led to her losing the baby. In another argument, Brett smeared his own blood on the walls and told Sandra the only way they would part would be through death. Eventually, Sandra succeeded in escaping Brett and obtaining a divorce. In 1975, Brett Morgan entered into another relationship with a woman named Christine. He borrowed huge amounts of money from her with promises to repay it. He said he was expecting a huge insurance payout from the death of his daughter.
她和布雷特后来和好了，暴力循环继续。桑德拉怀上了这对夫妇的第二个孩子，但在一次争吵中，布雷特反复殴打她的腹部，导致她流产。在另一次争吵中，布雷特把自己的血涂在墙上，告诉桑德拉他们分开的唯一方式就是死亡。最终，桑德拉成功逃离了布雷特并获得了离婚。1975年，布雷特·摩根与一名叫克里斯汀的女子开始了另一段关系。他以偿还为承诺，从她那里借了巨额资金。他说他正在等待一笔来自他女儿死亡的巨额保险赔付。
He also claimed he was about to inherit a $30,000 property from his recently deceased aunt. But Christine never got her money back. She would later find out Brat had no daughter or aunt. Christine wanted out of the relationship. One night when they were out for dinner, she told Brett she was leaving him. He seemed to accept this, but then when they were driving home, he suddenly stopped the car and said, If I can't have you, no one will. Then he grabbed her throat, hit her head against the car window, and began strangling her.
他还声称他即将继承他刚去世的姑姑的一处价值3万美元的房产。但克里斯汀再也没有拿回她的钱。她后来发现布雷特根本没有女儿或姑姑。克里斯汀想结束这段关系。一天晚上他们出去吃饭时，她告诉布雷特她要离开他。他似乎接受了这一点，但当他们开车回家时，他突然停下车说：“如果我不能拥有你，谁也别想拥有。”然后他抓住她的喉咙，把她的头撞向车窗，开始勒她。
Christine fought back desperately. Brett told her, You fucking bitch, I'm going to kill you. Nobody leaves Brett Morgan. Christine thought she was going to die. She was aware there was a police cruiser with its lights on up ahead and traffic had formed in a line behind it. Christine managed to open the passenger door and throw herself out of the vehicle. There was a taxi nearby and she got in.
克里斯汀拼命反抗。布雷特对她说：“你这个该死的婊子，我要杀了你。没有人能离开布雷特·摩根。”克里斯汀以为自己要死了。她意识到前面有一辆闪着灯的警车，后面排起了车队。克里斯汀设法打开乘客车门，把自己扔出了车外。附近有一辆出租车，她坐了进去。
Brett Morgan would later track her down and beg for her forgiveness through tears. but Christine left Canada for Florida and never saw him again. Then there was the case of Gwen Telford, the 21-year-old woman who Brett Morgan had killed in 1978. Gwen had a three-year-old daughter and did sex work to support her child. She was good friends with Brett Morgan's latest girlfriend, though Brett himself disliked Gwen and often made derogatory remarks about her. The three had lived together in shared economy.
布雷特·摩根后来追踪到她，并含泪乞求她的原谅，但克里斯汀离开了加拿大前往佛罗里达，再也没有见过他。然后是1978年布雷特·摩根杀害的21岁女子格温·特尔福德的案件。格温有一个三岁的女儿，靠做性工作来抚养孩子。她是布雷特·摩根当时女友的好朋友，尽管布雷特本人不喜欢格温，并经常对她发表贬损言论。这三个人住在一起，
until Gwen moved out in late October of that year. She began staying in a hotel while looking for something more permanent. At around 2.30 a.m. on Friday, November 3, Brett and a 17-year-old girl went back to Gwen's hotel room with her. The three sat around for about an hour, drinking a bottle of wine. Then Brett suddenly stole money from Gwen's purse and ordered her to undress. She did, Brett told the 17-year-old to go into the bathroom, or he would kill her also. He bound Gwen's hands behind her back with a pair of panty hose, then shoved her down on the bed. Brett then jumped on Gwen's chest and began choking her with his hands, stating,
直到格温在那年10月下旬搬走。她在寻找更稳定的住处时开始住在一家旅馆里。11月3日星期五凌晨2点30分左右，布雷特和一个17岁的女孩和她一起回到了格温的旅馆房间。三个人坐了一个小时左右，喝了一瓶酒。然后布雷特突然从格温的钱包里偷了钱，并命令她脱衣服。她照做了，布雷特告诉那个17岁的女孩去浴室，否则他也会杀了她。他用一双连裤袜把格温的双手反绑在背后，然后把她推倒在床上。布雷特随后跳到格温的胸口，用双手开始掐她，说道：
Die, you bitch, die. The 17-year-old hurt the killing from the bathroom. After Gwen was dead, Brett left the hotel with the 17-year-old and dropped her off at home. Gwen's body was found later that day by hotel cleaning staff. When the police began investigating her murder, Brett helped them with the investigation. Eventually, he was charged with and convicted of first-degree murder. But after it was found that the presiding judge had mischarged the jury, a second trial was held.
去死吧，你这个贱人，去死吧。这名17岁的少女从浴室里逃了出来。格温死后，布雷特带着这名17岁的少女离开了酒店，并将她送回了家。当天晚些时候，酒店清洁人员发现了格温的尸体。当警方开始调查她的谋杀案时，布雷特协助了他们的调查。最终，他被控一级谋杀罪并被定罪。但在发现主审法官误导了陪审团后，案件进行了第二次审判。
This time, Brett was instead found guilty of the lesser charge of manslaughter, and sentenced to 10 years. When Louise Ellis met Brett Morgan more than a decade later, she didn't know the full extent of his violent history. Instead, she was left struck by his courage in coming forward to testify for a wrongly incarcerated man. Louise later described their first encounter in her diary, writing, That morning, he insinuated himself into my life irrevocably. His words were carefully chosen, his voice resonant. I couldn't help but wonder what a nice guy like that was doing in a place like prison. Louise was a passionate and highly intelligent woman with strongly held convictions about right and wrong.
这一次，布雷特被判犯有较轻的过失杀人罪，并被判处10年监禁。当路易丝·埃利斯在十多年后遇到布雷特·摩根时，她并不知道他暴力历史的全部真相。相反，她被他挺身而出为一名被错误监禁的人作证的勇气所打动。路易丝后来在日记中描述了他们的第一次相遇，写道：那天早上，他不可逆转地闯入了我的生活。他的话语经过精心挑选，声音充满共鸣。我不禁想，像他这么好的人怎么会待在监狱这种地方。路易丝是一位充满激情、才华横溢的女性，对是非曲直有着坚定的信念。
She'd struggled with romantic relationships in the past, finding them hard to sustain when the early honeymoon phase gave way to the ordinary nature of everyday life. In Brett Morgan, she saw someone with whom she could have the all-consuming love she so desired. She was attracted to what she saw as his honesty and simplicity. His working-class background was very different to her middle-class one, but it was a case of opposites attracting. Above all, Louise appreciated how safe and loved Brett made her feel. Initially, from the outside, they appeared to be a happy couple.
她过去在恋爱关系中一直很挣扎，发现当最初的蜜月期让位于日常生活的平淡本质时，这种关系很难维持。在布雷特·摩根身上，她看到了一个可以与她拥有她所渴望的那种全心全意爱情的人。她被她所认为的他的诚实和纯朴所吸引。他的工人阶级背景与她的中产阶级背景截然不同，但这正是异性相吸的案例。最重要的是，路易丝很欣赏布雷特让她感到安全和被爱。起初，从外表看，他们似乎是一对幸福的情侣。
Yet, cracks started to appear even before Brett was released from prison. The couple swung between euphoric eyes and painful lows. They had screaming arguments over the phone, which left Louise drained and despondent. She never told her family members that her new partner had been convicted of manslaughter, instead telling them only that he'd committed fraud. After Brett was released from prison, the things that had initially attracted the law. Louise to him began to repel her. She found his tastes crude and realised how different their values and opinions were. While Louise was an intellectual who loved to read and debate ideas,
然而，甚至在布雷特出狱之前，裂痕就开始出现了。这对情侣在欣喜若狂和痛苦低谷之间摇摆不定。他们在电话里大吵大闹，这让路易丝感到精疲力竭和沮丧。她从未告诉家人她的新伴侣曾因过失杀人罪被定罪，而是只告诉他们他犯了欺诈罪。布雷特出狱后，最初吸引路易丝的东西开始让她反感。她发现他的品味粗俗，并意识到他们的价值观和观点有多么不同。虽然路易丝是一位热爱阅读和辩论思想的知识分子，
Brad didn't have an inquisitive mind at all. Within two months of moving in with Louise, Brett was already physically assaulting her. She wrote in her diary that he had shoved her, gripped her arm, poured beer over her head, pushed her down on the bed and refused to let her up, and punched a hole in the wall. He also made verbal threats. A tenant who resided on the upper level of Louise's home sometimes heard screaming coming from downstairs. Louise became overwhelmed by despair and self-loathing and wrote notes to herself on how she could be a better partner. These low points were punctuated by brief windows of joy, honeymoon phases where Brett would be affectionate and loving. One day, Louise wrote in her diary,
但布拉德根本没有好奇心。在与路易丝同居的两个月内，布雷特就开始对她进行身体攻击。她在日记中写道，他推搡她、抓住她的手臂、把啤酒倒在她头上、把她按在床上并不让她起来，还在墙上打了一个洞。他还进行了言语威胁。一位住在路易丝家楼上的房客有时会听到楼下传来的尖叫声。路易丝被绝望和自我厌恶所淹没，并给自己写了关于如何成为一个更好的伴侣的笔记。这些低谷期被短暂的快乐时光所打断，那是布雷特会表现得深情和充满爱意的蜜月期。有一天，路易丝在日记中写道：
I love going places with Brett. He's keen, he's beautiful to be seen with, he's friendly. The next day, she described an argument they had where Brett pinned her down and was frothing at the mouth. This relationship is either going to kill me or cure me, Louise wrote. The month before Louise went missing, she went to the hospital for x-rays after suffering a blow to her sternum. She told a number of friends and acquaintances that Brett was responsible. As well as learning about Brett Morgan's physical abuse of Louise, detectives discovered that he'd also taken advantage of her financially. Louise had always been very responsible with money and was a good saver. She supported Brett by buying him clothes, food and food and
我喜欢和布雷特一起去各个地方。他很热心，和他一起出现很有面子，他很友好。第二天，她描述了他们之间的一次争吵，布雷特把她按在地上，口吐白沫。这段关系要么会杀了我，要么会治愈我，路易丝写道。在路易丝失踪的前一个月，她在胸骨受到重击后去医院拍了X光片。她告诉许多朋友和熟人，布雷特对此负责。除了了解到布雷特·摩根对路易丝的身体虐待外，侦探们还发现他在经济上也利用了她。路易丝一直对金钱非常负责，是一个善于储蓄的人。她通过为他购买衣服、食物来支持他，并且
letting him move in with her. She also purchased a truck and tools for him as part of a home renovation business they started together named Morales, a portmanteau of their two surnames. But the business never took off and the brand new truck disappeared. Brett would say it had been taken by a biker gang that were shaking him down. The gang was supposedly extorting Brett as revenge for his testimony against his former cellmate, Larry Fisher. Louise complained to friends that Brett would take her bank cards without asking and withdraw cash. He rapidly drained her bank account and ran up her credit card debt. Four months before Louise vanished, Brett forged a check on her personal line of credit for $7,000.
让他搬进来和她一起住。她还为他购买了一辆卡车和工具，作为他们共同创办的一家名为Morales的家庭装修企业的一部分，这是他们两个姓氏的合成词。但生意从未起步，那辆全新的卡车也不见了。布雷特会说它被一个敲诈他的摩托车帮派抢走了。据称，该帮派勒索布雷特是为了报复他对他前狱友拉里·费舍尔的指控。路易丝向朋友抱怨说，布雷特会不经询问就拿走她的银行卡并提取现金。他迅速耗尽了她的银行账户，并欠下了信用卡债务。在路易丝失踪前四个月，布雷特伪造了一张她个人信贷额度的支票，金额为7000美元。
The next month, he forged another for $5,400. When Louise discovered Brett was six, he was saved. stealing from her, he claimed he needed the money to pay off the biker gang. Brett didn't just steal from Louise, he targeted her loved ones too. On one occasion, Brett helped out Louise's father by performing some repairs on his bathroom. After Brett left, Louise's father discovered that one of his credit cards was missing. It would later be traced back to friends of Brett's who used it in a shopping spree. Brett's abuse and stealing took a toll on the relationship, and in December 1994, Louise asked him to move out.
下个月，他又伪造了一张5400美元的支票。当路易丝发现布雷特在偷她的钱时，他声称他需要这笔钱来偿还摩托车帮派。布雷特不仅从路易丝那里偷钱，他还把目标对准了她所爱的人。有一次，布雷特帮路易丝的父亲修理浴室。布雷特离开后，路易丝的父亲发现他的一张信用卡不见了。后来追踪到是布雷特的朋友在购物狂欢中使用了它。布雷特的虐待和偷窃行为对这段关系造成了损害，1994年12月，路易丝要求他搬出去。
The following month, he moved into his own basement apartment, but he was told to leave in February after someone broke into the landlord's home upstairs. Louise took him back. They agreed it would be a temporary fix, with Brett moving out again on May 1. He had told investigators that their decision to live separately didn't mean their relationship was in trouble. By April 1995, Brett owed Louise more than $23,000. He said he would pay her back as soon as a friend from Toronto named Bob lent him the money. Bob was apparently going to wire Brett the money by mid-April and Brett would then transfer it to her. Louise was extremely anxious to receive the funds, telling friends she was down to her last $200.
次月，他搬进了自己的地下室公寓，但在2月有人闯入楼上房东的家后，他被要求离开。路易丝又收留了他。他们同意这只是暂时的解决办法，布雷特将在5月1日再次搬出。他曾告诉调查人员，他们分居的决定并不意味着他们的关系出了问题。到1995年4月，布雷特欠路易丝超过23000美元。他说，一旦他在多伦多的一个叫鲍勃的朋友借给他钱，他就会还给她。鲍勃显然打算在4月中旬给布雷特汇款，然后布雷特会把它转给她。路易丝非常渴望收到这笔资金，告诉朋友她只剩下最后200美元了。
She also told them that her relationship with Brett was over, whether he paid her back or not. She was sick of him controlling and using her. On Friday, April 21, the day before Louise went missing, she called her bank at least twice to check whether a bank transfer had come through. It hadn't. After police began bugging Brett Morgan's phone, they soon intercepted regular calls he was having with a Scottish woman named Marie Perrant. On Tuesday, June 15, about a month into Marie's contact with Brett, an Ottawa detective contacted her to ask how she knew Brett Morgan. Marie explained that she was an aspiring private investigator who had been working with Brad.
她还告诉他们，她和布雷特的关系结束了，无论他是否还钱。她厌倦了他对她的控制和利用。4月21日星期五，即路易丝失踪的前一天，她至少两次打电话给银行，询问银行转账是否到账。结果没有。在警方开始窃听布雷特·摩根的电话后，他们很快截获了他与一名叫玛丽·佩兰特的苏格兰女性的定期通话。6月15日星期二，在玛丽与布雷特联系大约一个月后，一名渥太华侦探联系了她，询问她是如何认识布雷特·摩根的。玛丽解释说，她是一名有抱负的私家侦探，一直在与布拉德合作。
Although she'd initially reached out to him due to sympathy, the truth was she'd been experiencing certain doubts ever since their second meeting. While listening over her tape recording of that conversation, Marie had noticed something strange. They had been discussing Louise's car and the way it was found. Marie asked Brett whether the driver's seat was still in the same position it would have been if Louise was the last to drive it. If it had been pushed back, that might indicate a taller man had left the car there. Brett replied,
虽然她最初出于同情联系了他，但事实是，自第二次见面以来，她一直心存疑虑。在听那次谈话的录音带时，玛丽注意到了一些奇怪的事情。他们一直在讨论路易丝的车以及它是如何被发现的。玛丽问布雷特，驾驶座的位置是否仍然和路易丝最后一次驾驶它时一样。如果它被推后了，那可能表明一个更高大的男人把车留在了那里。布雷特回答说：
Exactly the way I left. Then he abruptly stopped, as though catching himself and changed his answer to exactly the way Louise left it. On reflection, this struck Marie as suspicious. She'd also noticed other things. Most of Louise's clothing and jewelry had gone as though she wasn't expected to return, nor were there any women's toiletries in the home's bathroom. When Louisa's loved ones found out that Marie was working with Brad Morgan, none of them would speak to her.
完全是我离开时的样子。然后他突然停了下来，好像意识到了什么，把答案改成了完全是路易丝离开时的样子。回想起来，这让玛丽感到怀疑。她还注意到了其他事情。路易丝的大部分衣服和珠宝都不见了，好像没人指望她会回来，家里浴室里也没有女性洗漱用品。当路易丝的亲人发现玛丽在与布拉德·摩根合作时，他们都不愿与她交谈。
They were all convinced that he was behind her disappearance. Detective's Bob Pulfer and John Savage asked Marie if she would visit the police station and bring her taped interviews with her. She agreed. During their meeting, Detective Bob Pulver and John Savage asked Marie if she would visit the police station and bring her taped interviews with her. She agreed. During their meeting, Detective Bob Pulfer asked Marie what she thought had happened to Louise. She told him that she thought Brett Morgan had murdered her. This was the detective's belief as well. They asked Marie whether she would be willing to go undercover for them. When Marie asked what they would need her to do, Detective Pulfer replied,
他们都确信是他导致了她的失踪。侦探鲍勃·普尔弗和约翰·萨维奇问玛丽是否愿意去警察局并带上她的录音采访。她同意了。在他们的会面中，侦探鲍勃·普尔弗问玛丽她认为路易丝发生了什么事。她告诉他，她认为布雷特·摩根谋杀了她。这也是侦探们的看法。他们问玛丽是否愿意为他们做卧底。当玛丽问他们需要她做什么时，普尔弗侦探回答说：
Perhaps you could find out what Brett Morgan knows about the disappearance of Louise's. jealous. Marie agreed to help and Detective Savage looked at her, then jokingly said, well, maybe you could find the body too. From that point on, Marie Perrant was a double agent. At the police's request, she lied to Brett Morgan, telling him that she'd interviewed Louisa's ex John Maisorm with, and there were discrepancies in his story. She also claimed that a friend of John's told her about an argument between him and Louise. Brett had appeared stunned when she shared this information. Marie said that if they wanted John convicted of Louise's murder,
也许你可以找出布雷特·摩根对路易丝失踪了解多少。玛丽同意帮忙，萨维奇侦探看着她，然后开玩笑地说，好吧，也许你也能找到尸体。从那时起，玛丽·佩兰特就成了双重间谍。应警方的要求，她对布雷特·摩根撒了谎，告诉他她采访了路易丝的前任约翰·梅森·韦夫，他的说法存在矛盾。她还声称约翰的一个朋友告诉她关于他和路易丝之间的一次争吵。当她分享这些信息时，布雷特显得很震惊。玛丽说，如果他们想让约翰因谋杀路易丝而被定罪，
then they needed to find Louise's remains. She encouraged Brett to think of where Louise might be, telling him, with her perseverance and his criminal mind, they should find the body. Brett was quick to speculate where Louise might be, but he also seemed to harbour some suspicions about Marie. He began making references to undercover cops and told Marie that when a friend came to visit him, Brett had insisted on patting him down to check for hidden listening devices. Marie asked him if he thought she was an undercover cop.
那么他们就需要找到路易丝的遗体。她鼓励布雷特思考路易丝可能在哪里，告诉他，凭借她的毅力和他的犯罪头脑，他们应该能找到尸体。布雷特很快就开始推测路易丝可能在哪里，但他似乎也对玛丽怀有一些怀疑。他开始提到卧底警察，并告诉玛丽，当一个朋友来看望他时，布雷特坚持要搜他的身，检查是否有隐藏的窃听装置。玛丽问他是否认为她是卧底警察。
He laughed and said no. During their first search for Louise's remains, Brett pulled out a bandana and, without saying a word, wrapped it around Marie's neck. This scared her, as he had already told her how he had previously strangled a woman, so she pushed his hands away. Brett told her it was just a gift to keep her cool during the search. As they looked, a police helicopter hovered nearby. This clearly made Brett anxious and his search was lack. He looked like someone taking a casual walk through the woods instead of searching for a body. Marie told detectives how the helicopter had spooked Brett and they didn't dispatch it again.
他笑了笑说没有。在他们第一次寻找路易丝遗体时，布雷特拿出一块头巾，一言不发地围在玛丽的脖子上。这吓坏了她，因为他已经告诉过她他之前是如何勒死一个女人的，所以她推开了他的手。布雷特告诉她，这只是为了让她在搜寻过程中保持凉爽的礼物。当他们寻找时，一架警用直升机在附近盘旋。这显然让布雷特感到焦虑，他的搜寻变得漫不经心。他看起来像是在树林里散步，而不是在寻找尸体。玛丽告诉侦探直升机是如何吓到布雷特的，他们没有再派它出去。
Nevertheless, Brett appeared reluctant to search again after that, canceling plans a couple of times. Marie became more insistent and the two eventually met up at a restaurant. Brett admitted he sometimes wondered if Marie was an undercover officer, telling her she was, either that or a great actress. Well, I'm not, Marie replied. Brett began to hit on Marie, making suggestive remarks about her appearance and kissing her. She felt like throwing up, but instead kissed him back,
尽管如此，布雷特在那之后似乎不愿再进行搜寻，取消了几次计划。玛丽变得更加坚持，两人最终在一家餐馆见面。布雷特承认他有时会怀疑玛丽是否是卧底警察，告诉她她要么是，要么就是一个伟大的演员。好吧，我不是，玛丽回答。布雷特开始调戏玛丽，对她的外表发表暗示性言论并亲吻她。她想呕吐，但还是回吻了他，
terrified that if she didn't, her cover would be blown. This seemed to convince him, and the pair made plans to search again the following day of Thursday, July 6. After leading Marie straight to Louisa's remains, Brett Morgan began to sob and wail. To Marie, it looked like a performance. Then his eyes glazed over and he stared at her in a way that felt menacing. Worried that he might be regretting having led her to the body, Marie tried to play along by touching his face comfortingly and whispering soothing words. Brett then seemed to snap out of his sudden aggressive mood.
害怕如果她不这样做，她的掩护就会被揭穿。这似乎说服了他，两人计划在第二天7月6日星期四再次搜寻。在直接带领玛丽找到路易丝的遗体后，布雷特·摩根开始啜泣和哀号。对玛丽来说，这看起来像是一场表演。然后他的眼神变得呆滞，他以一种令人感到威胁的方式盯着她。担心他可能会后悔带她找到尸体，玛丽试图配合，安慰性地抚摸他的脸并低声说些安抚的话。布雷特似乎从他突然的攻击性情绪中恢复了过来。
They took photographs of the scene with a camera they'd brought along. Then Brett said he wanted to know how far they were from John Maison Weev's cottage. They drove to City Hall to examine a map. Brett estimated the spot where Louise Lay was roughly two. miles from John's cottage and said happily, that's pretty close, you know. Brett wanted to report the discovery to police, but Marie suggested they phone in an anonymous tip-off instead.
他们用随身携带的相机拍下了现场的照片。然后布雷特说他想知道他们离约翰·梅森·韦夫的小屋有多远。他们开车去市政厅查看地图。布雷特估计路易丝躺着的地方离约翰的小屋大约两英里，并高兴地说，你知道，这很近。布雷特想向警方报告这一发现，但玛丽建议他们打匿名举报电话。
After they parted ways, she phoned Detective Bob Pulfer and took him to the remains. Dental records confirmed they belonged to Louise. Because they were so badly decomposed, there was no way of knowing how Louise had been killed. But detectives had a theory. They knew that Louise was on the verge of leaving Brett, which would cut him off from her money. If she reported him for his fraudulent activity, his parole may be revoked. The bathroom was the only room in the house with no windows and nowhere to run. During a search of the home,
在他们分道扬镳后，她打电话给鲍勃·普尔弗侦探，并带他去了遗体所在地。牙科记录证实它们属于路易丝。由于腐烂严重，无法知道路易丝是如何被杀的。但侦探们有一个理论。他们知道路易丝即将离开布雷特，这将切断他从她那里获得的金钱来源。如果她举报他的欺诈行为，他的假释可能会被撤销。浴室是家里唯一没有窗户且无处可逃的房间。在搜查房屋期间，
police had noticed the shower curtain was missing. Brett had told them it ripped when he tried to clean it in the washing machine, so he'd thrown it out. But detectives suspected that Brett had attacked Louise while she was in the shower. He had probably strangled her, as he had Gwen Telford almost two decades earlier, and Louise had instinctively grabbed at the curtain, tearing it down. Brett had later wrapped Louise's body in the curtain and placed it in the trunk of her Suzuki sidekick Jeep. He had dumped her in a location close to John Maison Wev's property in an attempt to frame the other man. Because of Brett's criminal background, he knew he needed to deflect attention to another suspect.
警察注意到浴帘不见了。布雷特告诉他们，当他试图在洗衣机里清洗它时，它撕裂了，所以他把它扔掉了。但侦探们怀疑布雷特在路易丝洗澡时袭击了她。他可能勒死了她，就像他近二十年前对格温·特尔福德所做的那样，而路易丝本能地抓住了浴帘，把它扯了下来。布雷特后来用浴帘包裹了路易丝的尸体，并把它放在了她的铃木Sidekick吉普车的后备箱里。他把她丢弃在靠近约翰·梅森·韦夫房产的地方，试图陷害那个男人。由于布雷特的犯罪背景，他知道他需要将注意力转移到另一个嫌疑人身上。
Then he had abandoned Louisa's vehicle in a secondary location that was also near John's property before cycling home on a bike he'd stashed in the vehicle. Brett's seemingly cooperative demeanour and public pleas to the press were further attempts to appear innocent. It was a role he'd taken on previously after killing Gwen Telford when he initially aided police in their investigation. Although he appeared to be conducting his own searches for Louise in the first weeks after she went missing, police surveillance revealed he'd only spent a total of four hours and 45 minutes doing so. These brief searches took place over four different days in the area where Louise's car was found. In addition to searching with Marie Perrant twice, he'd also gone out once with a friend and another time with a reporter.
然后，他在靠近约翰房产的第二个地点遗弃了路易丝的车辆，然后骑着他藏在车里的自行车回家。布雷特看似合作的态度和对媒体的公开恳求，是他试图表现得无辜的进一步尝试。这是他在杀死格温·特尔福德后曾经扮演过的角色，当时他最初协助警方进行了调查。尽管他在路易丝失踪后的最初几周里似乎在进行自己的搜寻，但警方监视显示他总共只花了4小时45分钟。这些简短的搜寻发生在发现路易丝汽车区域的四个不同日子里。除了与玛丽·佩兰特搜寻了两次外，他还曾与一个朋友出去过一次，另一次是与一名记者。
There didn't appear to be any systematic searching. Police surveillance also revealed that Brett had started a new relationship with a woman just six weeks after Louise went missing, despite presenting himself as a grieving and heartbroken spouse, lost without his soulmate. The Gattano Hills were a sprawling area and there were so many secluded spots around the Wakefield area that police believed locating a body there would be like finding a needle in a haystack. They were certain that only Louise's killer was capable of finding her. Brett discovering Louise after very little searching finally gave them the evidence they needed to charge him.
似乎没有任何系统的搜寻。警方监视还显示，布雷特在路易丝失踪仅六周后就开始了一段新的恋情，尽管他表现得像一个悲痛欲绝、心碎的配偶，失去了灵魂伴侣而不知所措。加塔诺山是一个广阔的区域，韦克菲尔德地区周围有许多僻静的地方，警方认为在那里找到尸体就像大海捞针。他们确信只有路易丝的杀手才有能力找到她。布雷特在极少搜寻后就发现了路易丝，这终于给了他们起诉他所需的证据。
On the same day that Louise was found, detectives arrested Brett Morgan and charged him with first-degree murder. His trial began more than two years later in September 1997. It lasted six months, with more than 90 witnesses testifying, including private investigator Marie Perrant. Brett Morgan pleaded not guilty, with the defence arguing that the police had ignored all other possible suspects, such as Louisa's ex, John Mazormwev. After learning that Louise's partner had a criminal record, detectives had gotten tunnel vision
在发现路易丝的同一天，侦探们逮捕了布雷特·摩根并指控他犯有一级谋杀罪。他的审判在两年多后的1997年9月开始。审判持续了六个月，有90多名证人出庭作证，包括私家侦探玛丽·佩兰特。布雷特·摩根拒不认罪，辩方辩称警方忽视了所有其他可能的嫌疑人，例如路易丝的前任约翰·梅森·韦夫。在得知路易丝的伴侣有犯罪记录后，侦探们产生了隧道视野，
and focused exclusively on him. They also claimed that investigators didn't search for Louisa's remains in an attempt to goad Brett into doing so, and argued that Brett had no motive to kill Louise. She had helped him out financially and assisted in obtaining his parole. But the prosecution pointed to Louise's growing insistence on being paid back and her intentions to end to the relationship. They called numerous witnesses who testified as to Louisa's anxiety around her financial situation. In the days before her death, she was chasing up the funds Brett owed her and openly discussing how violent he was. The jury deliberated for three days before returning with a verdict. guilty. Louise's family and friends wept, shouted, applauded and hugged each other with
并完全专注于他。他们还声称调查人员没有寻找路易丝的遗体，试图诱使布雷特这样做，并辩称布雷特没有杀害路易丝的动机。她在经济上帮助了他，并协助他获得了假释。但控方指出了路易丝越来越坚持要求还钱以及她结束这段关系的意图。他们传唤了许多证人，证明了路易丝对财务状况的焦虑。在她去世前的几天里，她一直在追讨布雷特欠她的钱，并公开讨论他有多暴力。陪审团审议了三天，然后给出了裁决：有罪。路易丝的家人和朋友哭泣、欢呼、鼓掌并互相拥抱，
relief upon hearing the news. Brett Morgan was expressionless as he stated, I didn't do this, Your Honor. The judge addressed him, stating, You planned and deliberated upon the killing of Louise Ellis, a young woman in the prime of her life, who gave everything she had in an attempt to assist you in your reintegration into society. She was an intelligent, vibrant, highly creative, fiercely loyal and loving human being, who shall be sadly missed by her family and those who loved her. Implicit in the jury's verdict is that you wrongfully accused an innocent man, John Maison Weev, of being responsible. That treacherous act speaks very poorly about,
听到这个消息后感到如释重负。布雷特·摩根面无表情地说：法官大人，我没有做这件事。法官对他发表讲话，指出：你策划并预谋了杀害路易丝·埃利斯，一个正值青春年华的年轻女性，她倾其所有试图协助你重新融入社会。她是一个聪明、充满活力、极具创造力、极其忠诚和充满爱心的人，她的家人和爱她的人将深深地怀念她。陪审团裁决中隐含的意思是你错误地指控了一个无辜的人，约翰·梅森·韦夫，应对此负责。那种背信弃义的行为充分说明了，
your moral fibre. He sentenced Brett Morgan to 25 years without the possibility of parole. Afterwards, Brett's lawyer insisted that he believed his client was innocent and they would appeal the verdict. But two months into Brett Morgan's sentence, he died in prison due to hepatitis C. It was April 24, 1998, three years to the day since he had reported Louise missing. For Marie Perrant's role in convicting Brett Morgan, police awarded her $4,600. She later told the National Post that she was offended by this reward, saying, It felt like a slap in the face after all I had done. Over the years, Marie has appeared in multiple documentaries to discuss her role in the Louise Ellis case
你的道德品质。他判处布雷特·摩根25年监禁，不得假释。事后，布雷特的律师坚称他相信他的当事人是无辜的，他们将对判决提出上诉。但在布雷特·摩根服刑两个月后，他因丙型肝炎在狱中死亡。那是1998年4月24日，距离他报告路易丝失踪整整三年。对于玛丽·佩兰特在定罪布雷特·摩根中的作用，警方奖励了她4600美元。她后来告诉《国家邮报》，她对这个奖励感到被冒犯，说：在我做了这一切之后，这感觉就像是一记耳光。多年来，玛丽出现在多部纪录片中讨论她在路易丝·埃利斯案中的角色，
and has been working on a memoir about her time as a private investigator. After Brett Morgan's trial, Louise's father, brother and sister said that the result had restored their faith in the justice system. Although they were still overwhelmed by pain, knowing that Louise had been found and her killer punished helped somewhat. Louise's father Alan said he would forgive Brett Morgan for his actions, stating, Never return evil for evil. Never. After Louise's remains were recovered, a funeral was held at Glebe St. James United Church in Ottawa. 200 mourners packed into the space to memorialise Louise, who was remembered as a passionate,
并一直在撰写关于她作为私家侦探期间的回忆录。布雷特·摩根审判后，路易丝的父亲、兄弟和姐妹表示，结果恢复了他们对司法系统的信心。虽然他们仍然被痛苦所淹没，但知道路易丝被找到了，她的杀手受到了惩罚，这在一定程度上有所帮助。路易丝的父亲艾伦说他会原谅布雷特·摩根的行为，并指出：永远不要以恶报恶。永远不要。路易丝的遗体被找回后，在渥太华的Glebe St. James联合教堂举行了葬礼。200名哀悼者挤满了空间来纪念路易丝，她被铭记为一个充满激情、
artistic and intellectual woman who was deeply spiritual and had great integrity. She was an excellent cook and a very talented writer. In 1976, she wrote and illustrated a church. children's book titled The Alpha Vegetabet, which taught children about the alphabet and vegetables. The minister presiding over the service encouraged all those present to remember Louise's story, stating, If there is anger here this afternoon, I hope it is a righteous anger. Louise, her life and her death, calls us to action.
富有艺术气息和知识渊博的女性，她有着深刻的灵性，品格高尚。她是一位出色的厨师和非常有才华的作家。1976年，她编写并绘制了一本名为《阿尔法蔬菜》的儿童读物，教孩子们认识字母表和蔬菜。主持仪式的牧师鼓励所有在场的人记住路易丝的故事，并指出：如果今天下午这里有愤怒，我希望那是一种正义的愤怒。路易丝，她的生命和她的死亡，呼吁我们采取行动。
Women are abused, every day, and it is not wrong. right not now not before and not again There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
女性每天都在遭受虐待，这是不对的。现在不对，以前不对，以后也不对。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。